on
comme quoi stafa tchad astra ni sur nos
soldats tous nos mauvais temps qui ont
lieu qui avait comme emma la partie solo
dit sonia mettre la main à une autre
zone uc
bot en italien within l'étrange pensons
que [ __ ] vraiment du plaisir à
chantôme italien parce que la traduction
elle est encore plus qu'une eric le
texte qu'on sait mais c'est aussi jani
avec l'italien qui date de 2007
alors georges tu es tu y mets devenir
l'egypte oui comme beaucoup c'est votre
jour avec drucker on a recensé tous les
grecs dans une logique qui en a
quelques-uns s'appelle alexandrie
alexandrie qui avaient des études du pa2
qui était que ça va longer par le groupe
comme une langue je n'ai pas plus ou
moins bien c'est que je parle moins bien
sûr le grec parce que les hasards de la
guerre la première ce que la vitesse
avait fait en français j'ai pris goût
puis j'ai fait toutes mes études en
français dès que j'ai passé mon bac de
ce menu en français une peu de grecs que
je gardais s'éloigne de ma mémoire enfin
quand je retourne en grèce je retrouve
un peu maintenant mais ses rangs tu
parle italien espagnol anglais brûle
arabe portugais portugais tu as appris
la musique jeudi par petits bouts oui
lagon ses doigts de piano puis à 17 ans
6 mois de solfège à 18 et la guitare 20
ans oui bien c'est vrai j'aime explique
alors à 17 ans arrive à paris gare de
lyon
tu venais de débat n'est pas qu'à
marseille d'une arrivée d'égypte et bien
tu vas tu vas chercher du travail du
coran sacré des chansons déjà
non je fais je cherchais pas du travail
mais on propose assez vite
il s'agissait de vendre des recueils de
poèmes en porte à porte ou dans les
terrasses de café et c'est un travail
plaisant parce que le marché du porte à
porte n'était pas saturé alors nous
ouvrait la porte facilement il y avait
même des aventures extraordinaires qui
se passait des portes avait pas peur au
contraire c'était très excitant et tous
les groupes de jeunes gens qui faisait
ça c'était c'était des jeunes filles
avec qui on continue la soirée après le
travail c'était c'était vraiment pas un
travail pénible en plus été rentable
c'était par rapport à nos besoins à 7 et
rentable je veux dire on vivait la
bohème c'est vrai qu'on faisait pas des
repas gastronomiques mais on n'aura pas
de fin et on s'amusait beaucoup et puis
tu commences écrire des chansons et une
chanson pour mon temps salvador échos
mais j'écris des chansons et puis moment
peut-être plus embêtant il fallait les
montres et les timides ou timides
orgueilleux je ne peux pas savoir où les
deux on verra mais c'est que c'était
très pénible alors quelquefois la france
a joué en ma faveur par exemple un jour
je vais à la bc pour voir salvador que
j'adorerais que j'adore toujours voulu
montrer une chanson que j'avais écrite
en pensant lui
enfin pour ça qu'ils nous pour elle a
chanté il entre dans sa loge fait
toutefois une dame qui est l'un qui me
dit vous voulez voir henry je dis madame
vous avez un accent égyptien sous la
direction du wild et d'alexandrie
or la grande diffusion henri salvador en
tri persuadé que je suis un ami de
jacques lynn pascoe active d abord été
questionné c'était la famille
m'invite au spectacle vont même dîné le
nom de la chanson on l'a fait il
enregistre et puis m'a dit mais au fond
vous connaissez depuis longtemps
jacqueline et toi c'est connu le jour où
nous avions soulevés mais la chance ça
oui parce que plusieurs fois je suis
allé jusqu'à une porte de vedettes pour
montrer ma chanson je n'ai pas osé où
j'ai pas voulu comme je disais par vous
organisé par timidité je n'ai pas été
plus loin que le palier pu redescendre
et avec annick comment ça s'est passé là
encore là aussi c'était le hasard
bienheureux et agréable j'avais connu un
homme qui manque beaucoup à ma vie à la
vie de beaucoup qui s'appelait henri
crolla mari qui était le damier de
montant unitaire est de mon temps
formidable musicien guitariste
extraordinaire enfin je ne tarit pas
d'éloges pas c'est vraiment une des
personnalités importantes de ma vie dans
la musique et on avait un petit problème
qu'on aurait qui aurait pu nous opposer
l'histoire de deux heures qui se
rassemblent et le ciné lumière on devait
en discuter
quand on était en présence on a oublié
de s'engueuler ou de se chercher des
histoires on a plutôt envisager de faire
des chansons bien faire n'importe quoi
ensemble et dans le n'importe quoi faire
ensemble il y avait une rendez vous avec
les dit qu'ils veulent aujourd'hui on me
dit tu es avec moi on se quitte pas dit
normalement mais s'est dit ce n'est pas
quitter puis j'ai pas quitté et je ne
reste pas maintenant mais je suis entré
chez dit comme ça pour être avec roland
il me ramenait où que ce soit aurait
suivi
il se trouve que les choses se disaient
les armées mais j'avais pas encore
composé rien pour enit j'avais une
chanson que j'ai composée en espérant
rencontrer edith piaf un jour et j'ai
voulu la montrer dit
et puis j'étais ils sont peu dépassé par
les évènements fin 17 épreuves que tu ne
pensais oui j'étais pas près la
situation vous au piano ce qui n'est pas
mon instrument
prédilection j'essaie de lui jouer comme
ils étaient venus me voir chanter de
bord ils vont écrire des chansons joie
parce que c'est ce que vous êtes se
connaissent et nous montrer et puis
quelques mois plus tard elle m'a dit
cette chanson que tu m'avais montrer
parce qu'on était au tueur n'est fait
beaucoup de choses ensemble
qu'est-ce que c'était au fond et je lui
les jouets alors là dans le calme et
avec un lave et de la sollicitude donc
l'écouter plus de plus d'intérêt plus
d'attention et elle a aimé elle a fait
un très beau disque c'est une chanson
qui s'appelle logis temps la fille qui
n'a pas été commencées le gitan a dit à
la fille qu'importe le prix de l'amour
il faut pas le chanter parce que elle
afin disent tellement merveilleux elle a
fait plusieurs disques avec une chanson
mais celui là il est marqué d'une grâce
exceptionnelle
je crois même que dans l'absolu n'a
jamais aussi bien chanté
elle était dans une forme vocale tout à
fait tout à fait incomparable et puis
bon puis j'écris une chanson qui ont eu
plus de succès dont elle est un peu
oublié mais ça reste pour moi la chanson
que j'aime effet pourrait dit on à
connaître qu'elle a chanté
magnifiquement ya pas déjà fait me lob
pour elle oui mais l'enjeu lui les faits
sur mesure et ça j'aime ça d'ailleurs
j'aime bien écrit pour quelqu'un en
sachant que c'est quelqu'un l'a chanté
donc on s'identifie où on cherche les
mots y serait à la fois ce qu'on a envie
d'écrire mais ceux là personne peut
chanter ou fait un transfert des
sensibilités c'est très excitant c'est
un dédoublement de réciproque
il aurais tu as écrit pour les gens si
différents montants salvador comme ricco
comme barbara gianni connaître l'art
jeanne moreau jeanne moreau nous
roger mais tu oublies quelqu'un qui
était important parce que c'était une de
mes idoles de l'adolescence et tino
rossi
ah oui bien sûr bon j'ai créé jeunes
gens voulaient absolument ne pas finir
ma carrière de compositeur sans écrire
pour tous nous et grâce à un film qui
s'appelait jusqu'au bout du monde vous
ai fait la musique réalisateur mehdi
faudra faire une chanson parce que le
film s'est passé en corse et la jeune
victime rossi j'ai eu le plaisir tous
les jours qu'a duré pendant les
répétitions de nouveau passé des heures
avec lui et cette tête je crois que
c'est une des dernières chansons des
derniers succès de steam ou cette
chanson et ça c'est une grande
récompense
là tu vas partir sur les routes faire
détourner la partir de dans quelques
jours je fais une très grande tournée en
espagne qui étale se disait j'ai trouvé
plusieurs patrie sur ma route d'espagne
est un pays que je n'ai connu qu'après
le franquisme parce que j'ai une censure
il a exercé comme certaines chansons
c'est pourquoi elles ne sont pas si si
vraiment nous disent des choses que je
pense on me réalise bien les choses
aussi oui entre les chansons en espagnol
les jeunes hanovre ce que je suis
français depuis peu mais je suis un
chanteur français depuis longtemps
j'ai ensuite à un français depuis s'il
s'était confirmée mais je chante partout
sauf au japon en allemagne en espagne en
amérique du sud du nord en français
parce que je pense que la chanson est
intraduisible